[Música]
estas dos parejas de amigas celebran una
victoria los primeros certificados de
Unión gay expedidos por Tokio un sistema
puesto en marcha el pasado mes de
noviembre un reconocimiento oficial para
estos homosexuales
nuestra relación Ya es sólida Entonces
no cambiará
una carita
pero ahora podemos desarrollar una
relación de confianza con los otros sin
escondernos ser sinceras y eso da
seguridad
estas dos japonesas se conocieron en
Estados Unidos pero fue tan solo a su
regreso a Japón que se volvieron pareja
una historia de amor de hace más de 11
años cuando se enteraron de que Tokio
ponía en marcha esa Unión estuvieron
entre las primeras en registrarse
nos tomó dos minutos rellenar el
formulario
hay homosexuales que no han salido del
clóset y que temen se reconocidos en la
alcaldía Entonces el hecho de que sea en
línea es un buen sistema
hasta ahora era imposible para las
parejas Case de Tokio obtener un
préstamo bancario como familia o tomar
una decisión de tipo médico para el
cónyuge en caso de urgencia Incluso el
acceso a vacaciones estaba restringido
como las empresas no reconocen ahora
como una pareja oficial podemos
organizarnos para una licencia de
maternidad por ejemplo en el caso de los
suegros que se enferman ahora podemos
justificarlo para ausentarnos en Japón
la homofobia es poco frontal pero está
presente pocos son los que están listos
para asumir una relación homosexual aquí
los grupos homofóbicos influyen hasta en
las más altas esferas del Estado el
pasado mes de junio una manifestación de
una parte del partido en el poder causó
un escándalo se distribuyeron folletos
en los que se califica la homosexualidad
como una enfermedad mental o dependencia
en Tokio la capital del mundo el barrio
de shinjuku nichome es la excepción una
pequeña decena de calles donde los
colores arcoiris son exhibidos con
orgullo mano de pollo
Me da seguridad es por ello que vengo
en este bar hay gente bisexual como yo
me parece que en unión gay es un avance
muy positivo
con frecuencia son los adultos mayores
los que no están de acuerdo
con tan solo 24 años choco es uno de los
jóvenes gerentes de este bar homosexual
vela sobre este espacio sin tabú cuya
libertad sigue siendo frágil
en este bar hay japoneses que esconden
su homosexualidad hago parte de una
generación donde la gente dice Okay
los lgbtq más existen Pero no se dan
cuenta realmente
pienso que será más fácil para las
próximas generaciones
algunas administraciones municipales
japonesas lanzaron certificados de Unión
desde 2015 Tokio Se demoró siete años en
optar por esta vía para la metrópolis
era difícil hacer las cosas más rápido
[Música]
es importante que los habitantes de
Tokio las empresas y las
administraciones comprendan la
iniciativa
para contar con su apoyo tuvimos que
trabajar mucho tiempo hasta ahora
en Japón es difícil cambiar las
mentalidades las parejas Case prefieren
con frecuencia presentarse como rummade
así ello implica erradicar un expediente
menos sólido ya que algunos propietarios
rechazan alquilar a parejas homosexuales
en cuanto al arriendo de vivienda al
final es el propietario quien decide o
no no podemos obligarlo mediante la ley
a pesar de los años de espera el
certificado no se acompaña de ningún
dispositivo legal para impedir las
discriminaciones contra los gays un
avance relativo por ahora solo
cuatrocientas parejas han solicitado el
certificado en una metrópolis de 14
millones de habitantes y su documento no
será válido en todo el país Japón es la
última nación del g7 que no acepta el
matrimonio homosexual dar finalmente a
los gays los mismos derechos que los
heterosexuales es la lucha de esta
pareja una norteamericana y una japonesa
instaladas con su pequeña hija en kyoto
rodeadas de otras parejas gays
protestaron contra la prohibición del
matrimonio homosexual en el tribunal ven
en ello una violación a sus derechos
fundamentales un proceso histórico
este proceso era necesario son cuatro
años Durante los cuales se progresó así
la justicia de osaka haya concluido que
constitucional en la prohibición del
matrimonio gay y para nosotros eso no es
aceptable
van a apelar reconocen El Avance de los
certificados de Unión pero creen que se
trata de una falsa solución dichos
documentos no les dan derecho a las
parejas gay de tener hijos
entonces la que no parió no tiene ni
siquiera autoridad parental no puedo
ponerme apellido en el registro de
nacimiento es como si no tuviésemos
ningún lazo
como si no tuviésemos relación alguna
tercera persona así somos considerados
su hija nació en Japón pero no pudo
obtener la nacionalidad japonesa una
extranjera en su país de nacimiento
consideraron irse a Estados Unidos pero
las dos mujeres rechazan abandonar Japón
según una encuesta realizada el año
pasado hoy en día el 57% de los
habitantes del archipiélago estaría a
favor del matrimonio homosexual